For this problem, we have a sad Galileo.
You can tell because well he's dropped his object and now he wants to get it back.
Unfortunately, the leaning tower is very high and he doesn't want to walk all the way down.
Luckily, Galileo has a friend--this makes him slightly happier but he still wants this thing back up here.
He's going to repeat his experiment--that's how you get good data.
Good thing that Galileo also has a rope, and let's say his friend ties this rope to the object.
Now, we're talking. Now, Galileo's feeling pretty weak today.
He can only pull upwards with the force of 25N.
Can you tell me what would be the acceleration of the apple?
I highly recommend you draw a force diagram, and when you do, once you get an answer--enter here.